hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Jessica Jones episode five through
eight video really freeing the David
Tennant beast all over the computer
screen or you know however you guys are
watching it he really is fantastic as
this villain seriously purple man on
jessica jones is way better than he is
in the comics just careful for spoilers
on jessica jones through episode eight
so we're basically starting with Jessica
before killgrave all the way up to the
point where she does what would Jessica
do and she takes him to that special
cell favorite moments from this bakit
episodes were the hot dog saved meat
like Jessica dressed in the hot dog
costume before a kilgrave saving the
little girl who walked into the middle
of the street killgrave in the police
station when the phone rings and he
loses his the next person whose
phone rings has to eat it and I think
the most effed up moment is when hope
finds out that she's pregnant with
kilgrave's baby tries to induce an
abortion by having the other prisoners
beat her then they went up themselves
when jeryn hogarth takes the fetus to
try and experiment on it secretly momen
the fetus snatching probably the most
effed up thing that's happened in the
series so far that's really what the
series vacillates between kind of funny
tongue-in-cheek effed up moments and
like really oh my god holy effed up
moments there are a couple moments in
this block of episodes where the plot
drags just a little bit like the energy
really goes crazy in episode 5 we get
some Captain America Avengers Easter
eggs which is like why don't you go
after the big green guy or the flag
we're like you see the little kid
running in the Captain America costume
the woman here you might recognize from
friends she kind of goes after Jessica
for being super-powered people blaming a
lot of the collateral damage from the
Avengers battle with the our on
anybody with powers Jessica's like that
wasn't me man go after the big green guy
in his squad so you probably recognize
that a big thing with the series is
showing how people deal with their
trauma for better or for worse the idea
is that Jessica the the lead of the show
has really shitty relationship with
herself in one of the beasts
quote-unquote that she has to slay by
the end of the series include including
kilgrave he's like a physical beast that
she has to slay is that she has to slay
a lot of her mental demons her family
died when she was a teenager not her
fault all the people around her dying
when kilgrave is there not her fault
killgrave abducting her the first time
when she tried to be a hero not her
fault
so that's actually a bigger demon
Firdous Lee I think then kilgrave
himself like there is some big stuff
that happens after episode 9 that lot
the safe for another video but but she
essentially she starts jumping over
these big mental hurdles like slaying
some of these demons but the big arcs
early on are one trying to get killgrave
the first time her first attempt to take
him down she doesn't try to get luke
cage's help they have trouble working as
a team and it goes terribly then there's
a Luke Cage arc with him finding out
about how his wife died and splitting
with Jessica like her / blaming herself
from that don't you wonder if he was
actually gonna kill that MTA card before
she came clean she's like he didn't do
it he didn't do it I killed your wife
but his effed up as she treats herself
killgrave always finds a way to one-up
her and be like the most messed up
person on the show he buys her childhood
house and then goes through it
meticulously making it look exactly like
it did when she lived there seriously he
said that he took a magnifying glass
from pictures that he got from a realtor
to find the stack of CDs in her room to
make it look exactly like it did when
she lived there but actually when she is
at her childhood home living with Co
grave like that whole sequence one of
the most fun moments is her trying to
get kilgrave to use his powers for good
and I think he's being completely 100%
honest when he says you need to stay
with me because I don't know the
difference between good or bad seriously
I thought it was a good idea to have
that man shoot his face off she kind of
realizes that he's not like she's like
so she has to ponder the question
of whether or not she can use his powers
for good is it worth it having to live
with him and sacrifice the rest of her
life
just a circle back around for some of
the biggest comic book Easter eggs so
there is like a Heroes for Hire moment
when she and Luke Cage team-up then we
see the jewel costume from the comics
that's her actual comic book superhero
costume from when she almost became part
of the Avengers calling out some big
flaws in superhero costumes nowadays
they'd have to call me camel toe if I
wore that whenever a female actress has
to wear a swimsuit or anything that's
really revealing usually the easy fix
for camel toe is gaffer tape his crazy
as that sounds that's an old Hollywood
trick people actually do that but they
did change some things about how Jessica
ran afoul of the purple man the first
time like she saves her future roommate
on the street who's being mugged and
kill grape walks up and is like oh my
God look at you you're fantastic
so what happened in the comics is is
that Jessica Jones intervened at a
restaurant altercation and it just
happened to be the purple man so it was
a similar type of encounter in the
comics but happened inside a restaurant
and it was not her future roommates that
she was trying to help the interesting
thing about her breaking free so like on
the TV show it kind of shows that she
slowly develops an immunity to the virus
that he emits but in the comics she only
broke free when the Avengers helped her
what happened is is kilgrave's sent her
to kill daredevil but she ran into
Scarlet Witch mistook her for daredevil
tried to kill her but the Avengers
teamed up and beat the crap out of her
and then saw what was going on and tried
to help her for better for worse if
you've read the purple man in the comics
he does do more terrible things like the
things that he does are much much worse
but you'll probably agree the David
Tennant's version is a much more fully
formed character there's more of an
actual person there and it's really
fascinating to learn why he is the way
he is which actually doesn't happen till
a little bit later in this series I'll
talk about that when I get to like my
episode 9 to 12 video because it is
absolutely fascinating what happens in
episode 9 here's my big question for you
guys let me know in the comments what
were your like favorite funny moments
from episodes 4 through 8 and what was
like the most messed up thing for you I
think we can all probably agree that the
dead fetus was probably the most messed
up moment finding out that jeryn hogarth
was like hey you know wait why don't you
save that if you can as of me making
this video I'm only at about episode 10
so there's still like a ways to go most
of you guys that I've seen commenting
who have already finished the series do
say that you like the way it ends so I
am looking forward to the big finale if
you guys have finished the series and
you have big questions or comments about
stuff that happens after episode 8 just
please use spoiler tags in the comments
what's gonna happen later tonight is
there's a new episode of Doctor Who
episode 10 a whole bunch of WTF stuff
happens so I'll be posting a video for
that in a couple hours
my next Jessica Jones episode video
might not post till Monday just because
there's a whole bunch of stuff happening
on Sunday give it like Game of Thrones
Walking Dead my next Jessica Jones
episode video might not post until
Monday just because so much is happening
on Sunday we have new Game of Thrones
and new Walking Dead so just be sure to
subscribe to get everything and if you
guys didn't see I just posted a new
flash arrow crossover trailer where I
named the reverse flash ring giveaway
winner so I'll put a link in the
description just in case you guys
haven't seen it you can click
here for the link to that falero trailer
where i do the reverse flash ring
giveaway a whole bunch of hawkman
hawkgirl vandal savage stuff going on
and you can click here for all my
Jessica Jones episodes thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you